how many times can you crash a plane oh
I'm gonna mightiness you sitting next to
me hold my hand can
we're not even holding our hands there's
a bald can what happened you're bald
taking you away I can see the flying axe
in the background you see it - yeah how
did we find each other look at that look
at that Buddha okay oh sorry my face you
made your crotch go through my face
thank you like spoon you're right oh my
god
calling somebody with your I'm calling
her spoon to tell him Daisy food look at
this alright look at it 360 yeah what's
gonna be what what am I doing here it's
flying I'm fine yes
spoon I told you it was a good like I'm
going obtain you're the Messiah
I am the Millea come on let's have a
bath together buddy
oh yeah he wouldn't wanna wash my back
some pie mmm-hmm yeah just turn around
yeah yeah like that yeah I'm watching
we're trying to make you relax buddy we
just been through okay you move through
the water you crouch down just like look
it's Lucy the lizard oh no Lucy Lizzie
Lizzie Lizzie you gonna eat her kiss her
this will bring good luck to us play
real-life minecraft almost yeah no I
think that's what not told them to do
sorry sorry sorry did you die I swing at
the leaves
it's oh he said he's [ __ ] climbing
the mountain and [ __ ] do you see that
that's right he's way out there are you
just for that what is he doing
who program that can we build a can we
fight
oh do you see the water kind of glitch
out over there yes like a triangle
nice Illuminati confirmed let's build a
house boat but I can tread water with
400 pounds of wood on my shoulder
I'm stout well they're floating so it's
not like that but all right let's really
here then you have nice man titties by
the way I have to compliment him you and
I working on them for a long time
me and Taco Bell been working together
well we can faster together that's all
know that yeah we just did we're like
real lumbermen jacks we need to be a lot
faster we've gotta make it before the
night may go ow
I used to be so beautiful
now III get it oh my photo was ready oh
my bunghole is so ready alright I be
inside this thing I have a be inside it
you ready yes Jesus I'm over here what
are you doing over there
wait I'm selling it the house is here
no that's here no the house is here now
you're of it wait wait did we did we
clone the universe oh you're just
standing in the water oh man I mean I'm
in the house
alright you're loading us a freaking
make house tree huh I knew now we can
fight them fight me oh is that is that
kill him he's down he's down dammit
there's so many what are we doing Ken
how I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I have
no help I see doing I see dark I see
dark I can't see it faker system so that
it's out where are you kid
hey what you say gonna famiiy can gonna
hold em tight
okay I'm Alma what are they doing
they're just looking at your house it's
beautiful so you are in the house now so
now that I dived my house died - no
animal my spirit house is dead
all right grabbed oh like my stuff and I
would I don't even know where this came
from
hey guys hey guys how you doing you
wanna come in my house huh you like this
house don't you [ __ ]
they don't even care freakin a lot of
them no no no no what are you Jesus dude
oh god please protect me I don't wanna
die distract I've literally distract no
health distract Madam's distract them
show them you man boobs oh I think I'm
gonna make it I think oh yeah help help
help
damn it I'm not it's not going anywhere
it's getting light though no it is it oh
nice lightning effects Jesus
yeah yeah they didn't open up by hey my
face is out of the window
how's words are just the best this is a
great idea
oh they're still following it oh no what
have any flip dammit
hey there are you doing in this guy's
just hanging out the side of the window
here peeking out no you're not for me
you're like arms are sticking inside
there you go now it looks good oh oh
we're here okay all right well I'll
leave my house there before you know
what we can build a gazebo and get
married
can't wait yeah like a cold yeah it's a
gazebo
way over here hello you can feel like a
zebra in this game it's like you your
son got missing in the woods bet it
being a gazebo nice relaxing spot to
lounge are you out of stamina too cuz
I'm really yeah just like the boat
action just too much diet you skinned it
instantly oh no this is blood dude dude
dude I smashed a deer with a stick and
money came out I'm not even kidding my
[ __ ] money came out what the hell
money is coming out of this deer the
other deer there's four deers what are
you king of deer Aziz I'm [ __ ] oh it's
running it's trying to run alright I got
it this is trying to run to come back
here I really need food
I'm really really starving for hours and
there's some mushrooms give me mushrooms
me Oh mushrooms - ah they're poisonous
hate more than ah it burns so good at
least I'm not hungry anymore huh just
one little slap with a stick just
instantly makes them bloody and dead
yeah yeah ever I can stab it I know I
can stab it alright there we go there we
go you see this there's a guy watching
this back there behind me wait yes
see money comes out this guy is telling
the money comes out from penetrating his
butt
only this was real life Shannon the
shark is another dead sure there's a lot
of dead sharks here
I flew like hundred meters up in there I
walked on the shark and he's just
launched me the shark is like now
there's a dead shark and I launch like a
bounce I'm going behind it it doesn't
even realize you don't see fins oh no
they're for me now you have to go a
little further out I think no safe ready
yeah oh the shark mood what the hell the
dead shark is moving what is he doing it
they're moving they're all of them
moving that's terrifying
zombie shark see they move for you no
[ __ ] it's so creepy
the other one is moving too I think you
launched when they even launched
something I'm trying to stand on it and
then maybe I go to the moon to the moon
baby go shark Oh short go no we're going
inside the cave will they make it out of
lab or will they day so much water near
that goes under water yeah don't don't
question it alright I hope I see a
flying shark in you mine I looked
everywhere for my limit oh yeah some
dead people
ah ah ah penis people pokum I speared
this guy like 10 times I swear to God I
got I'm gonna die because he I damn it
my limit on damn it
ah wait wait for me wait oh hey you know
what nice you just came up
you can't believe your hands yours like
look at my hands do you want to just
hang out here and have some plain food
instead [ __ ] Tammie Maine so we don't
have any axis
our stuff is stuck in a cave and we're
where we started with nothing I think we
should a god you scared the [ __ ] guys
cry here
like this video if you enjoyed
suck my ass brofist